hallo guten Abend und Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live
Europa regelt seine Außengrenzen für
flüchtende zunehmend ab das hält viele
Menschen aber bis jetzt nicht davon ab
die gefährliche Überfahrt über das
Mittelmeer zu wagen in der Hoffnung auf
einen besseres Leben mit zum Teil
furchtbaren Folgen erst in der
vergangenen Woche ist ein Boot mit
Migranten vor der griechischen Küste
gesunken 80 Todesopfer wurden
mittlerweile geborgen vermutlich sind es
aber mehrere hundert die ums Leben
gekommen sind darunter auch viele Kinder
hier solche Katastrophen passieren im
Mittelmeer immer wieder und dabei spielt
Tunesien eine wichtige Rolle für viele
Migranten auf ihrem Weg nach Europa das
Land ist Ausgangspunkt für die Route
nach Italien allein in diesem Jahr kamen
mehr als 26.000 Menschen von Italien
nach von Tunesien nach Italien im
vergangenen Jahr also 20022 waren es zur
gleichen Zeit nur rund 4000 auf dieser
Fluchtroute
ja wie illegale Migration stoppen und
welche besondere Rolle nimmt Tunesien
dabei ein darüber wollen wir heute abend
reden mit der Tunesien Expertin Irene
weippert-fenner und mit Viktoria ritig
von der Deutschen Gesellschaft für
auswärtige Politik schickt uns gerne
eure Fragen und eure Kommentare die
werden wir dann gerne weiterleiten ihr
könnt das in die Chats posten oder ihr
schickt einfach eine E-Mail und damit
wollen wir jetzt beginnen guten Abend
Frau ritik
hallo guten Abend Frau ritik warum ist
das so das aktuell gerade wieder so
viele Menschen nach Europa wollen
das hat verschiedene Gründe vor allem
dass wir sehr viele verschiedene Krisen
gleichzeitig haben also wir haben die
Ukraine Krise natürlich mit den sechs
Millionen Vertriebenen aber auch viele
andauernde Krisen in Afrika und dem
Nahen Osten dazu gehört natürlich Syrien
aber auch die wiederaufflammende Krise
in Afghanistan und deswegen sind die
Zahlen von Flüchtlingen auch sehr stark
gestiegen wir haben gerade neue Zahlen
vom flüchtlingswerk UNHCR gesehen dass
wir weltweit mittlerweile 35 Millionen
Flüchtlinge haben also ein immenser
Anstieg im Jahr im Vergleich zum Jahr
davor und deutschland ist das Land was
die viert meistens Flüchtlinge weltweit
beherbergt und das sehen wir natürlich
dann auch bei den asylantragszahlen die
in Deutschland 75 % gestiegen sind im
Vergleich zum Vorhersagen genau da kann
ich mit ein paar Zahlen auch dienen die
Deutschland betreffen die schauen wir
uns kurz an ja die Zahl der Menschen die
in Deutschland Asyl beantragen ist eben
wie gesagt auch gestiegen im letzten
Jahr wurden von Jahresbeginn bis Anfang
Juni 71
1122 Erstanträge gestellt in diesem Jahr
waren es im gleichen Zeitraum schon
insgesamt
125.566 Erstanträge das ist genau eine
Steigerung um
76,6 Prozent ja das sind Zahlen die für
die Bundesländer und für die Kommunen am
kaum noch zu bewältigen sind wie sie
sagen und daraus entsteht ja dann auch
ein gewisser Handlungsdruck den will die
EU jetzt mit Asylzentren an den
Außengrenzen lösen das ist ein
Kompromiss den Deutschland ja mitträgt
kann das funktionieren
das ist noch nicht das noch völlig
unklar ob das funktionieren wird wir
haben jetzt erstmal nur die Einigung im
EU-Rat das ist diese Reform geben soll
da jetzt wird das noch besprochen
zwischen Rat und Parlament und dann wird
gegen Ende diesen Jahres oder Anfang
nächsten Jahres dann entschlossen ob es
tatsächlich zur Reform kommt so aber
diese Einigung im EU-Ministerrat letzte
Woche war natürlich sehr wichtig weil
sie ein paar neue Anstöße gebracht hat
wenn diese Reform kommen sollte die
unter anderem auch schnell Rückführung
von Menschen vorsieht deren Asylanträge
dann in sogenannten grenzverfahren
abgelehnt werden dann braucht die EU
eben auch Tunesien und andere
Nachbarstaaten
und es Kern Interesse der EU ist eben
auch in der Unterhaltung mit Tunesien
dass diese Länder nicht nur ihre eigene
Staatsbürger zurücknehmen sondern eben
auch andere Migranten die durch Tunesien
und durch diese Länder migriert sind und
das sind natürlich vor allem Menschen
aus Suppe Sahara Afrika und deswegen
gibt es dieses Treffen zwischen Faser in
Italien und mit dem mit
und dem Präsidenten Tunesiens aber das
ist auch nur das follow-up-treffen zu
dem Treffen was das letzte Woche gab
zwischen der kommissionspräsidentin von
der Leyen und den Regierungschefs von
Italien und die Niederlanden die
ebenfalls nach Tunesien gefahren sind
mit der Mission ein migrationsabkommen
weiter zu treiben und haben da ein
ganzes Paket mitgebracht von Anreizen um
Tunesien da auch Zusammenarbeit zu
bewegen absolut Frau ritig erstmal
vielen Dank für den Moment sie haben es
eben schon gesagt Frau Innenministerin
ferser war eben heute in Tunesien weil
Deutschland eben parallel zur eu-eigene
Lösung sucht wir schauen uns mal an
worum es da genau ging
bei Tag und bei Nacht greift Tunesiens
Küstenwache Boote voller Menschen auf
dem Weg nach Europa auf angezogen vom
hiesigen Wohlstand
in dieser Zeit mehr und mehr geworden im
Vergleich zu den vergangenen Jahren hat
die Zahl deutlich zugenommen
europäische Politiker wollen das ändern
gemeinsam mit dem französischen
Innenminister sprach Nancy fazer heute
in Tunis über legale Zuwanderung für
Fachkräfte und Abschottung gegen andere
das geht darum dass furchtbare sterben
im Mittelmeer zu beenden es geht um
Menschenrechtsstandards es geht darum
auch
legale Wege zu schaffen damit Menschen
in Europa
einwandern können aber nicht sich auf
gefährliche Wege begeben müssen und
dabei spielt eine ganz wesentliche Rolle
auch die gemeinsame Bekämpfung von
Schlepper und schleuserkriminalität die
in aller drei Länder Interessen liegt
Unterstützung soll von allem dazu dienen
tunesische Polizei und Grenzschutz
Truppen zu verstärken um den illegalen
Flüchtlingen Einheit zu gebieten und
ihre Rückkehr zu erleichtern Tunesien
selbst ist das erste Opfer der
ungeregelten Migration deswegen möchten
wir unsere Solidarität zu Ausdruck
bringen
den werben begegnet Tunesiens zunehmen
autoritäre Regierung kühl schon früher
hatte der Präsident betont man sie sich
nicht als Wächter für andere der
Innenminister äußerte sich nach dem
Gesprächen heute nicht tun ist spielt
auf Zeit mit jedem neuen Boot steigt der
Druck auf Europa
und wir sprechen jetzt mit der Tunesien
Expertin Irene weippert-fenner vom
Leibniz-Institut hessische Stiftung für
friedens- und Konfliktforschung schön
guten Abend schönen Abend hallo wir
haben es gerade gehört es besteht am
Handlungsdruck von Seiten Deutschlands
wie sieht denn von tunesischer Seite aus
ja das ist eine gute Frage denn
tatsächlich hat Tunesien ganz schön
Druck und zwar wirtschaftlicher Natur
durch Corona und durch die Verwerfungen
durch den Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
ist die soziologische Lage in Tunesien
sehr sehr schwierig und immer wieder
wird von der Zahlungsunfähigkeit
Tunesiens gesprochen seit Ende letzten
Jahres ist eigentlich ewf-abkommen
verhandelt gewesen was der Präsident
nicht durchbringen wollte aufgrund der
wieder mal sehr schmerzhaften
Konditionen die darin drin stehen würde
und ohne dieses Abkommen rechnet man
aber eigentlich mit der
Zahlungsunfähigkeit Tunesiens Tunesien
ist extrem abhängig von Nahrungsmittel
Importen
mit einer abgewerteten Währung steigt
die Verschuldung täglich also
tatsächlich ist der Zeitdruck auch bei
Tunesien wo die Menschen durch die
Preissteigerungen aber durch
Nahrungsmittel Knappheit wirklich leiden
und generell auch die Arbeitslosigkeit
sehr sehr hoch ist also die soziale Lage
insgesamt sehr angespannt ist und
jegliche finanzielle Unterstützung die
von außen kommen könnte eigentlich
insights Interesse wäre aber es macht
natürlich auch Sinn für ihn einen Preis
weiter zu treiben darauf werden wir
gleich noch mal zu sprechen kommen
schauen wir uns mal etwas genauer an was
der Innenministerin denn vor schwebt
also ein migrationsabkommen mit
sogenannten
talentpartnerschaften was soll das sein
wie soll das aussehen
also wir werden mal genau schauen was am
Ende dabei herauskommt tatsächlich ist
das Thema Arbeit und Beschäftigung
Tunesien ein sehr zentrales bei der
Revolution 2011 war Beschäftigung eine
der zentralen Forderungen und hatte
sogar die bekannten Revolution Slogans
geschafft und seitdem ist Beschäftigung
oder gerade die Arbeitslosigkeit unter
jungen Akademiker in Tunesien das
soziale Problem wenn man jetzt mit
talentpartnerschaften kommt sagt
Fachkräfte aus Tunesien eine weitere
Chance außerhalb des tunesischen
Arbeitsmarkt Liezen will dann ist das
natürlich auch für seit eine Lösung den
sozialen Sprengstoff den er in seinem
eigenen Land hat etwas zu entschärfen
andererseits ist natürlich auch die
Gefahr des sogenannten braindrangs hier
dass man also die gut ausgebildeten
Leute aus dem Land rausholt und für den
wirtschaftsausschung den Tunesien ja so
dringend bräuchte dann dass das Human
Capital nicht mehr da ist man muss dazu
sagen der Arbeitsmarkt in Tunesien
zwischen 50 und 80% der Menschen sind
informell beschäftigt also ist die Frage
wer sind denn wirklich Talente kommt man
auch an diesen informellen Sektor ran
würde man eine Talente auch fördern vor
Ort oder würde man quasi nur die gut
ausgebildeten dann direkt nach Europa
holen oder wer hier sagen ein
wechselseitiges
eine wechselseitige Beziehung seitens
Deutschland mit Tunesien auch weiter
angedacht das werden wir jetzt mal sehen
noch wie viel Interesse das dann konkret
bringt die die Fachkräfte abzuziehen
aber sein Beschäftigung das Thema
generell ist die soziale Frage in
Tunesien
aber dann möchte sie ja auch noch
geordnete rückführungsprozesse wie sie
das nennt also das sind im Prinzip da
geht es darum dass Menschen ohne
Bleiberecht dann eben freiwillig nach
Tunesien zurückkehren
sollen und dieser Vorgang soll auch
beschleunigt werden sie kennen Tunesien
sie kennen das Land wie realistisch ist
das
also bis jetzt zumindest haben wir
gesehen dass mit den
Rückführungsabkommen die wir bisher
haben sehr wenig das tatsächlich
umgesetzt wurde weil das Geld generell
für die Region wenn ich Interesse daran
besteht wie der junge Leute zurück ins
Land zu holen die wieder auf den
Arbeitsmarkt kommen und dort keine
Beschäftigung finden
wir müssen nur eine Sache noch mal klar
sagen wenn wir sagen wir schicken Leute
zurück nach Tunesien da geht's ja noch
um die Diskussion um sichere
Herkunftsländer
tunesien hat sich auch so kritisiert das
war vorher im Beitrag auch schon zu
hören da werden wir sicher auch noch mal
drüber sprechen aber hier es gibt
bereits politisch Verfolgte Journalisten
werden inhaftiert
juristenanwälte werden Richter werden
entlassen also die Repression generell
hat den Tunesien stark zugenommen also
einfach geflüchtete Menschen
zurückzuschicken das geht nicht also
einfach nur als sicheres Herkunftsland
zu deklarieren das kann meine Tunesien
nicht mehr bringen
ja sie sagen es Tunesien Geld ja
wirklich mal als Hoffnungsträger in
Sachen Demokratie da hat sich einiges
geändert Jonas gab fast zusammen
von hier gegen die Bewegung aus die
weite Teile Nordafrikas und des Nahen
Ostens erfasste Tunesien im Jahr 2011
Start des arabischen Frühlings in den
nächsten Jahren folgt der
wirtschaftliche Aufschwung Touristen
kehren zurück an die Strände Tunesiens
2019 gilt Tunesien laut demokratieindex
als einzige Demokratie in der arabischen
Welt die Präsidentschaftswahl
entscheidet der Jurist kajes Sayed für
sich eine der hoffnungsfiguren des
arabischen Frühlings nach der Revolution
wirkte er an der neuen Verfassung mit
doch in seiner Amtszeit verfolgt feiert
einen autoritären Kurs lässt
Oppositionelle inhaftieren und geht
gegen die Pressefreiheit vor das sorgt
für Widerstand im eigenen Land am 12
Jahrestag der Revolution gibt es
Proteste gegen den einstigen
Mitgestalter des arabischen Frühlings
anders ist auch die Wirtschaftskrise in
der Tunesien steckt
im Land kommt es im Februar zu Gewalt
und Schikanen gegen Migranten aus
anderen afrikanischen Ländern kritiker
werfen Sayed vor sie durch seine
Äußerungen befeuert zu haben auch
deshalb versuchen viele Menschen nach
Europa zu gelangen
schauen wir uns das vielleicht noch mal
genauer an warum hetzt Präsident seit
gerade so sehr gegen flüchtende aus
anderen Teilen Afrikas
ich denke es ist zum einen kann man
nicht ausschließen dass er wirklich
selber rassistische Motive hat er
spricht auch ja mal gerne von
Verschwörungstheorien in eine davon ist
der bevölkerungstausch der angeblichen
Tunesien drohen würde dass Menschen und
suchte Haare Afrika Tunesien zu einem
afrikanischen Land machen würden und
sagen nicht mehr einer kein arabisches
Land mehr wäre
man muss dazu sagen diese
Verschwörungsideologien die natürlich
nicht nur in Tunesien also etwas weit
verbreitetes der Landwirtschaftsminister
in Italien hat das gerade erst selbst
erzählt dass Italien sozusagen Angst vor
dem Bevölkerung Tausch hat also damit
ist seit nicht allein ob er wirklich
daran glaub weiß ich nicht ich kann nur
spekulieren dass er ausgerechnet jetzt
diese Karte gezogen hat im Februar März
und zwar aufgrund der schlechten so zu
ökonischen Lage die ich vorher schon
erwähnt also sein klassisches Sündenbock
Phänomen dass man das sozusagen die
alten narrative die er die ganze Zeit
sonst fährt das sein korrupte Eliten die
die die nationale Sicherheit bedrohen
wollen oder auch noch die islamistische
Karte das ist ja noch mal auch ein ganz
starkes Motiv von es sei jetzt
Demokratieabbau gewesen die nachblase
die moderate islamistische Partei wieder
sondern stark zu beschneiden und zu
unterdrücken dass dieses narrativ nicht
mehr verfangen hat und dass man quasi
jetzt versucht woanders die Schuld
abzuladen und rassistische Motive
rassistische Elemente die es in Tunesien
auch gibt wie wahrscheinlich leider in
jeder Gesellschaft aber die noch mal zu
befördern und da muss man auch sagen die
Gewalt die er damit geschürter die
richtete sich ja nicht nur gegen
geflüchtete Menschen sondern eigentlich
jeden Menschen mit schwarzer Haut das
können schwarz
schwarze Tunesien innen sein das können
aber genauso gut Studierende
Afrika sein die hat diese Gewalt genauso
getroffen also es ging wirklich nur um
geflüchtete sondern klarer rassistisches
Phänomen und ich würde denken dass das
eben mit der schlechten Wirtschaftslage
zusammenhängt und die ganze Euphorie die
rund um Zeit bestanden das war ja gerade
im Beitrag zu hören Jahr 2019 er war
sozusagen bei einer hoffnungsbringer
weil er das Thema Beschäftigung das
Thema Arbeitslosigkeit im
marginalisierten Hinterland von Tunesien
stark gemacht hat und da den Unmut über
die fehlende revolutionsdividende sagen
eine Person gegeben hat und ein Ventil
gegeben hat das auch in die Institution
kanalisiert hat aber nichts geliefert
hat ja diesen Frust würde ich
einschätzen hat er nun ähm auf Menschen
mit schwarze Haut projiziert und
gleichzeitig wollen ja auch viele
tunesiererinnen und Tunesier das Land
verlassen das hat ja auch viel über die
Situation im Land aus welche
Zukunftsperspektiven sehen sie gerade
es ist schwer einzuschätzen weil seit
wirklich ein populistischer Herrscher
ist wie wir die auch aus anderen
Kontexten ein bisschen die USA kennen
und diese Herrschaft Eliten zum Teil
wirklich schwer einzuschätzen sind ich
habe es gesagt wirtschaftlich steht er
im Rücken zur Wand und jetzt öffnet sich
diese Tür die EU die die Kooperation
sucht und an demokratischen Standards
nicht weiter interessiert zu sein
scheint zumindest nicht von kein
Konditionen gehört habe die sei es jetzt
Unabhängigkeit der Justiz
meinungsversammlungsfreiheit ähm faire
Prozesse etc solche
Konditionen zu bringen davon habe ich
bisher nichts mitbekommen dann hat er
quasi eine Möglichkeit jetzt doch noch
Einnahmen zu haben mit denen er sich
weiterschafft es ist eine Art durch
wurschteln wenn man so salopp sagen
möchte und dieser Ansatz den hat man
leider bei dem sämtlichen Regierung seit
der Revolution gesehen dass keine
wirklichen Lösungen keine Visionen daran
wie man ein Land das ja viel Potenzial
hat auch aufgrund der Nähe zu Europa
hier auf dem wirtschaftlichen
Fortschritt bringen könnte denn die
Strukturen sind die alten geblieben
bereits der Diktatur zeichnete sich die
Wirtschaftslage aus das Insider rund um
die herrschaftselite profitierten sei
das jetzt im Arbeitsmarkt im
öffentlichen Sektor aber auch Ulf
Unternehmerseite und hier hat sich nicht
wirklich viel geändert diese Insider
sind nach wie vor beschützt bekommen
auch ein gutes sozialpaket und diese
vielen Exkludierten also was ich vorher
schon meinte informeller Sektor aber
auch viele Unternehmen Privatsektor die
ist einfach nicht schaffen vorwärts zu
kommen weil diese Trennung zwischen
diesen Fähren so stark ist die auch
entmutigt bestimmte bildungszweige oder
Investitionen in die eigene Bildung zu
tätigen weil es sowieso nur mit connecte
in das System hinein funktioniert an
diesem an dieser Struktur hat man nichts
geschafft wirklich was zu verändern und
ob sie das eine wirklich schafft das
glaube ich und überhaupt nicht weil er
sich eher so eine alten Wohnung oder Sie
herauskommt also quasi alte Eliten
die aus der burgi-zeit und über
Jahrzehnte Familien die sich hier
gehalten haben
vertritt und diese Interessen wieder
stark macht vor allem gegen eben die
Islamisten die andere Event ihre eigenen
Leute versucht haben ins System zu
bringen also es gab nicht wirklich in
Strukturwandel und den wird eher glaube
ich auch nicht bringen also werden
nämlich eher an dass wir kurzfristig
immer wieder von einem drohenden
Zahlungsausfall zum nächsten gehen aber
leider sehe ich im Moment keinen
wirklichen Game changer für Tunesien wie
soziale Gerechtigkeit und soziale
Inklusion wirklich gestaltet werden
könnte jetzt haben sie Situationen im
Land beschrieben vielleicht zum Schluss
noch ganz kurz die Frage
wäre Tunesien denn unter diesen
Umständen wie die Situation im Land
gerade ist überhaupt ein verlässlicher
Partner für so einen migrationsabkommen
die Frage ist wirklich was verlässlich
hier bedeutet ja also man muss sagen
ganz klar ist Gewaltmonopol besteht
Militär und Sicherheitskräfte so
funktionieren wenn man so will die sind
auch ganz klar auf der Seite von sei
jetzt also wenn es nur darum geht mit
Repressionen legaler wie von uns
kritisch zu sehen da Menschen in Lagern
zu halten und davon abzuhalten auch gute
zu kommen dann könnte er wahrscheinlich
verlässlich sein ob wir diesen Menschen
aber wirklich Menschenrecht konforme
Bedingungen garantieren können das sage
ich durchaus zu bezweifeln die
rassistischen Ausführungen habe ich ja
vorher schon erwähnt aber woher können
wir denn sicher wissen dass hier
Menschenrechtsstandards eingehalten
werden wenn wir keine unabhängigen
Medien haben wenn es zu Verstößen kommt
und Justiz nicht unabhängig ist und
diese Antennen kann also wenn die
Gewaltenteilung generell ja in Tunesien
nicht funktioniert werden Diktator
zusammenarbeiten der die
Sicherheitskräfte unter seiner Kontrolle
hat und mehr nicht also wenn uns das
sagen als verlässlicher Partner reicht
das finde ich sehr sehr fragt Feedback
und letztendlich darf man auch nicht
vergessen sind Autokratien gerade
repressive
tatsächlich selber Flucht Ursache also
wenn wenn wir ein Thema mit Migration
haben dann sollten wir schauen dass wir
in Tunesien nicht eine Diktatur weiter
stützen und zwar
was heißt nicht ohne Grund oder ohne
Motive aber letztendlich grundlos
tunesien hat selbst Anreize mit uns zu
kooperieren wir sollten Maßstäbe
einhalten wir sollten Sie einfordern
justizmädchen Unabhängigkeit zumindest
diese Blöcke wieder einzurammen und ja
dann werden wir sehen ob ja wie
verlässlich ist da jetzt sich dann zeig
wenn wir wirklich wissen können was vor
Ort passiert und es nicht darauf
verlassen müssen was Staatsmedien und
sagen und das richte die um ihre eigene
Zukunft fürchten müssen müssen
urteilen was den Präsidenten beliebt
Frau Zenner ich danke Ihnen ganz
herzlich für das Gespräch machen das Gut
tschüss
ja und damit kommen wir dann gerne noch
mal zurück zu Viktoria ritik von der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für auswärtige
Politik Frau ritik schön dass sie noch
bei uns sind wir haben heute auch mit
Pro Asyl gesprochen genauer gesagt mit
Wiebke Judith von Pro asyl-asyl und da
würde ich Ihnen diesen Motoren dieses
Statement kurz vorspielen gerne
bei Tunesien stellt sich sicherlich auch
die Frage inwieweit damit nicht ein
autokratisches Regime gefestigt wird
anstatt vielleicht demokratische
Elemente im Land zu stärken und das ist
eben auch leider eine Kontinuität die
wir in den letzten Jahren häufig gesehen
haben dass die EU oder eben auch die
deutsche Bundesregierung ja Regierung in
anderen Ländern aus
migrationspolitischen Interessen stärkt
die aber sich eben nicht unbedingt im
eigenen Land für Demokratie und
Menschenrechte einsetzen und wir haben
eben zuletzt gesehen dass in Tunesien
als auch eine starke Hetze gegenüber
Migranten aus anderen Ländern und
gegenüber Flüchtlingen gibt außerdem ist
Tunesien vielleicht auch nicht für alle
Menschen zum Beispiel jeglicher
sexuellen Orientierung sicher und das
ist eben das Problem bei solchen Deals
das natürlich solche Schicksale damit
komplett umgangen werden und eben
Menschen auch in für Sie unsichere
Situation zurückgebracht werden können
wir haben jetzt zwei Stimmen gehört die
das durchaus kritisch sehen wie sehen
Sie das ist das nicht problematisch für
ein Land wie Deutschland ein Deal
fließen zu wollen mit Tunesien wenn man
am weiß wie die Lage dort aktuell ist
natürlich höchst problematisch auf jeden
Fall die Frage ist aber auch immer was
sind denn die alternativen Länder mit
denen man dann so ein Abkommen schließen
könnte und da sieht natürlich ganz genau
aus Tunesien ist zumindest auf dem
Papier noch eine Demokratie das ist
etwas was für viele der anderen
nordafrikanischen Länder wenn nicht gilt
oder für alle anderen und deswegen ist
es natürlich so dass das Deutschland und
auch Europa eben versuchen zumindest mit
den Partnern zu arbeiten die auf dem
Papier zumindest noch im selben System
beheimatet sind das ändert aber
natürlich nichts an der Tatsache dass es
eine unbequeme Wahrheit von
migrationsabkommen ist dass sie leichter
geschlossen werden können und auch
leichter umgesetzt werden mit Auto mit
Autokratien und mit Demokratien die eben
ins autokratische
Abrutschen denn dann können
Demonstrationen der Bevölkerung
natürlich die Regierung nicht so stark
beeinflussen wie funktionierende
Demokratie und ich denke genau das sehen
wir gerade in Tunesien
das heißt dass eine Demokratie wie
Deutschland am Ende indirekt davon
profitiert dass sie eben an ein Pakt
schließt mit einem Land in demokratische
Strukturen aktuell nicht funktionieren
und sie sagen aber auch gleichzeitig es
ist eine Frage der alternativen aber
trotzdem macht sich Deutschland eben
nicht erpressbar wenn es mit solchen
Staaten auf dieser Art und Weise
zusammenarbeitet ja das Argument der
Erpressbarkeit ist ein ganz wichtiges
und die große Kritik wenn wir solche
Abkommen abschließen dann entsteht eine
Abhängigkeit und eine Erpressbarkeit und
wie es ganz wichtig zu betonen vorsicht
das stimmt so nicht ganz denn unsere
Abhängigkeit die existiert ja unabhängig
von den Abkommen ja sie besteht also
selbst wenn wir kein Abkommen haben das
abschließende Abkommen verstärkt unsere
Abhängigkeit und unser preisbarkeit also
nicht notwendigerweise sondern sie macht
sie eher kalkulierbar
dazu schreibt am Benny im Chat auf
Youtube den Fall wie in der Türkei
sollten wir auch nicht vergessen der
Flüchtlinge am Ende als Druckmittel
benutzt hat also da geht es um das
migrationsabkommen mit der Türkei das ja
momentan der Faktor ausgesetzt ist
genau also das Risiko von
Instrumentalisierung von Migration also
das aktive Fördern von migrationsflüssen
von irregulären migrationsflüssen das
existiert natürlich aber auch hier
wieder dieses Risiko existiert auch
unabhängig davon ob wir einen Abkommen
haben mit der anderen Seite oder nicht
ja also wir haben auch z.B mit Belarus
hat gegenüber der Europäischen Union
eine klare Fall von
migrationsinstrumentalisierung versucht
im Jahr 2021 erinnern uns an die Krise
dort an der Grenze und da ist da besteht
natürlich kein Abkommen mit denen ja
dass ich will nur sagen dass die dass
diese Abkommen das war ähm das war
institutionalisieren ein Stück weit das
Quitte was existiert aber die
Erpressbarkeit grundsätzlich ist auch so
da und wenn wir das Abkommen haben dann
legen wir fest was beide Seiten tun
müssen damit eben ein fragiler Status
entsteht der dann für beide Seiten ein
wenig besser ist als das hier ohne also
ohne Abkommen hätten
aber das ist natürlich ethisch und
moralisch völlig fragwürdig ist das ist
klar
sven hat noch eine Frage auf Facebook er
fragt warum sollten die starten denn
überhaupt einen Interesse da dran haben
die Staatsbürger zurückzunehmen
das ist ja das Problem dass eben viele
Staaten wenig Interesse daran haben ihre
eigenen Staatsbürger zurückzunehmen in
manchen Staaten existiert ein in
größeres Interesse daran Leute
zurückzunehmen vor allem wenn es um gut
qualifizierte Leute geht um die Frage
von Brain wiederum aber bei vielen der
Staaten in die Deutschland und Europa
gerne mehr Menschen zurückführen möchte
ist das natürlich nicht der Fall und die
der Unwillen von Ländern ihre Menschen
zurückzunehmen ihre Staatsbürger
zurückzunehmen selber ist ja einer der
größten Faktoren der so schwer macht
nämlich diese rückführungsprozesse und
die Rückführung aus Deutschland und
Europa auch tatsächlich wahr werden zu
lassen und genau deswegen haben wir ja
auch ein immer stärkeren Fokus auf die
interne Dimension eben weil wir in der
externen Dimension also in der
Zusammenarbeit mit den anderen Ländern
oftmals auch Graniten
so hier ist noch eine Frage von Heiko
wieso reden wir denn hier von
Deutschland wieso macht er nicht die EU
ein Abkommen mit Tunesien
die EU unterhält sich natürlich auch mit
Uni betonesien wie ich gesagt habe es
gab letzte Woche ja auch die Reise von
von der kommissionspräsidentin gemeinsam
mit einigen der Regierungschefs aber
natürlich hat Europa zwar einiges im
Gepäck was es als Paket auch anbieten
kann aber nicht alles und eine der ganz
wichtigen Sachen was die EU eben nie im
Gepäck haben kann vollumfänglich sondern
nur die nationalen die die Staaten
selber also Deutschland selber Italien
selber das sind die legalen Wege denn es
sind die Mitgliedstaaten der
Europäischen Union selber natürlich die
die Visa ausstellen und die bestimmen
können wer in ihr Land reisen kann und
wer nicht und genau deswegen ist es auch
durchaus sinnvoll dass eben es diese
zwei Reisen gibt das also auf der einen
Seite auf der EU Ebene gesprochen wird
aber auf der anderen Seite auf der
bilateralen Ebene zwischen Deutschland
das soll ja auch noch weitere Abkommen
Folgen zum Beispiel mit Georgien und
Moldau kommt was zum Fluss vielleicht zu
unserer Ausgangsfrage zurück was muss
denn aus ihrer sich t passieren um ähm
illegale Migrationen einzudämmen
es müssen sehr viele Puzzleteile
zusammenkommen um irreguläre Migration
einzudämmen natürlich gehören
migrationsabkommen dazu und selbst wenn
wir kein Abkommen schließen muss eine
Form von Zusammenarbeit existieren mit
den Ländern um uns herum ein anderes
Puzzleteil ist natürlich ein besser
funktionierendes migrations- und
Asylsystem der Europäischen Union da
versucht man ja hinzukommen ob das
schaffen ist noch unklar natürlich ist
ein großer Punkt legale Wege schaffen
natürlich das ist ein wichtigeres
Puzzleteil von dem wir auch immer wieder
hören aber Vorsicht letztlich gibt es
irreguläre Migration und vor allem die
erzwungene Migration natürlich immer da
wo es Krieg Krisen not
Perspektivlosigkeit gibt und wir haben
zur Zeit weltweit eine Situation wo es
einfach immer mehr Menschen gibt die
Schutz brauchen und gleichzeitig immer
weniger Länder die bereit sind diesen
Schutz auch zu bieten und solange wir
diese beiden gegenläufigen Entwicklung
haben solange werden auch die besten
migrationspolitiken die irreguläre
Migration nur ein Stück weit einnehmen
können
das heißt es würde auch in Richtung
gehen Fluchtursachen weiter zu bekämpfen
diese Frage gibt es hier noch im Chat ja
fluchtursachenbekämpfung ist auf jeden
Fall ein wichtiger Teil da muss man
unterscheiden zwischen den direkten
Fluchtursachen wie Krisen Konflikte
aber krisenkonflikte
not Perspektivlosigkeit bad governance
gehört auch dazu aber natürlich auch die
indirekten Fluchtursachen wie z.B die
Klimakrise ja wie zum Beispiel der
demografische Druck also immer mehr
Menschen einem Land ohne das
gleichzeitig auch Jobmöglichkeiten
geschaffen werden dafür haben wir ja
vorhin sehr viel gehört im Beispiel
Tunesiens also selbstverständlich müssen
all diese Fluchtursachen angegangen
werden und es ist auch durchaus der
richtige Ansatz aber auch hier wieder
wir brauchen auch einfach ein
realistisches erwartungsmanagement wie
viele Fluchtursachen in den vielen
vielen Ländern die um Deutschland und
Europa herum sind tatsächlich angegangen
werden können erfolgreich ja und
Deutschland und Europa es gibt einen
schönen satzani migrationspolitisch geht
es immer darum zu sehen kann ich mit den
Nachbarn die ich habe und aus der
Geografie aus der ich auch nicht
wegkomme eben bestmöglich
zusammenarbeiten und genau und das dabei
Konflikte natürlich entstehen das ist
klar und genau das sehen wir heute bei
den Besuch von von Phaser in Tunesien
und das werden wir auch weiterhin sehen
diese Konflikte zwischen unseren
ethischen und moralischen Ansprüchen was
für Systeme wir eigentlich fördern
wollen und unserem Druck mit welchen
Ländern wir aber zusammenarbeiten müssen
wenn wir diese Probleme und diese
Herausforderung angehen wollen und wir
werden weiter beobachten in welche
Richtung sich die Politik der bewegt und
welche Lösungen sie findet Frau ritig
ich danke Ihnen sehr für ihre
Erklärungen haben Sie noch einen guten
Abend tschüss
ja und den wünsche ich euch natürlich
auch ZDF heute live schön dass ihr dabei
wart bis bald tschüss
[Musik]